now some establishment republicans you
might have noticed this have kind of
shied away from focusing on cultural
issues in an election year out of fear
that it would alienate some voters
but along with the economy these
hot-button social issues they're driving
a lot of the political energy this cycle
so states pushing radical social agendas
are actually pushing residents to the
limit
some even fleeing to red states for a
reprieve from all of this in other words
people are voting with their feet
and they may be voting with their
subscription dollars as well
we're talking about netflix netflix has
lost a lot of subscribers now it's
probably not one reason for this we're
not going to try to diagnose it but they
did say as well they've lost a
considerable number last quarter due to
pulling out of russia
but they also project they'll lose
another 2 million next quarter
so what is driving this has the streamer
hit this kind of natural ceiling or is
this a cultural battle playing out
before our eyes at least in part
elon musk is betting on the latter
tweeting of the subscriber drop the woke
mind virus is making netflix unwatchable
now it's hard not to see that as driving
at least some of this while might not
contribute to all of the decline
it sure as heck is contributing to the
lack of expansion at the very least
there's
don't look up the star-studded climate
change movie about a world-killing
climate comet
there's a 100
chance that we're all going to die there
it is
a giant comet hurtling its way
towards earth can you see it
or these offerings
growing up with white parents i assumed
their privilege was mine
you're too good okay fine thanks
yeah i'm good too thanks you know i'm
the only black person in four of my five
classes but you're half white too you
can fit in anywhere
i fit in no room
dear white people counting down till the
day i graduate
maybe the lesson is this
when a company caters to ideology pushes
an agenda over just the needs and wants
desires of its consumers they're going
to suffer
and as netflix shares tumble consider
this over the past year
no dow stock has performed worse
than this
and disney and we're talking about
disney and they're dropped joining me
now is amala epinobi prager you
personality and former left-wing
activist amala between disney's dow drop
and the subscriber drop of netflix
uh there's something happening here what
are your thoughts on this
you know i'm with elon on this i think
it's this woke mine virus and people are
waking up and inoculating themselves
from it they don't want to hear this
anymore and netflix is known to be doing
this they put out a french film called
cuties with 11 year old girls with
barely any clothes on twerking and
shaking their butts on film they have a
series called you where they denounce
people who are anti-coveted vaccine
they're full of propaganda they've
subscribed themselves to anti-whiteness
anti-racism radical feminism and that's
what they put in their content you can't
find a piece of netflix content that
does not have leftist ideology embedded
in it and i think people are fed up with
it they don't want to pay a monthly fee
to be lied to and to be fed propaganda
and to be told that they are hated so i
think that's why subscribers are leaving
in mass although i think there are other
contributing factors
yeah amala i think the
the fact is people have limited dollars
to spend and it's like you don't want to
go into a bar if the bartender is going
to just scream at you and obscenities at
you and say how much he hates you you go
to a different bar right so if you can
exactly stream other content why are you
going to stream
netflix if indeed you believe too much
of the con i'm not talking about all the
content but
too much of the content is either
pornified or
just directly politico political now
here's a
comment from 2019 from netflix's ceo
watch
as a consequence of slavery jim crow and
housing policy black families in america
have about one-tenth of the wealth of
white families
if every major corporation takes one
percent of their cash
and deposits it in a black bank it will
be transformative in that sector
so amela he made a plea for reparations
he didn't use the word reparations but
i can't imagine that went over
well with some of the shareholders
no not at all and it's not going well
with the consumers of netflix either i
as a black person do not want to hear
this demeaning message about how i need
help from you and how i need help from
the rich and how we need to invest in
black business what is netflix doing for
black people or for lower income
communities virtually nothing when this
whole black lives matter scandal broke
out and people were taking to the
streets what did netflix do they opened
up a category on their streaming service
for black creators in black content not
only segregating their consumers and
creating a divisive climate but doing
nothing for black people in their
efforts it makes no sense it's all
virtue signaling and it's all propaganda
that's all that they want
what's wrong with having a black writers
or black producers category
we don't need to be uplifted it sort of
comes with this message of this soft
bigotry of low expectations that because
you are a black creator we need to lift
you up we need to separate and create
some deviation between you and other
people you cannot fix segregation with
more segregation
well that's just kind of a simple idea
but it really does resonate amla great
to see you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else